people love the internet hello and
welcome back today we are talking all
about orb of water an incredibly
powerful spell that is absolutely
tearing it up in PvP right now I would
not be at all surprised to see this card
get banned in the next week if you guys
didn't know once you hit Platinum rink
you actually get to vote on two spells
each week that you want to remove from
competitive play for that week so far
we've had Norwegian Ridgeback in my
region as well as the pure totem
locomotor but I don't think they can be
banned back-to-back weeks so I expect
that orb of water will be one of those
that gets banned next week so this spell
the reason is so good is it does
incredibly high damage and it also
controls the player in this orb of water
allowing them to move around and
basically take you into other areas so
maybe they have an atmospheric charm
maybe they have an area where Cassandra
is patrolling in Duos it gets even more
insane because you can have the partner
helping them set up all these kinds of
crazy combos where they essentially
could have both players trapped in the
orb of water an incendio going
underneath I mean it's just crazy what
you can do with this spell now that
being said there are some ways to get
out of the spell that's what we're going
to talk about first how you get out of
it there are also some ways to minimize
the damage maybe you can't get
completely out of it but maybe you have
a card in your hand at the right time
that's going to help you minimize damage
and then lastly the worst case scenario
would be that you have no cards in your
hand to help you get out of it and you
have no cards in your hand to do some
free damage to them the only other thing
you can do is be really smart and not
play certain things because you can
actually take the situation of you being
caught in the orb of water and make it
worse you do not want to do that alright
so first let's talk about the absolute
best case scenarios which would be
guaranteed ways to get out of the spell
my personal favorite is esposo esposo is
my favorite way to get out of the spell
it only costs 2mp it has a pretty decent
range on it so if you look at the range
here it's got a range of 28 the damage
is not high but you're not really
concerned about damage all you're
concerned about is getting them knocked
out of this spell so then that frees you
from the orb of water that is your main
focus now if it's a good player they're
going to be smart and they're going to
be moving around so they're not going to
be standing stationary with orb of water
if you have a player with a standing
stationary it should be relatively easy
to get out of as long as you have the
right card in your hand at the right
time esposo will do that perfectly but
if they're a decent player and they've
been playing for a while they're going
to be moving around while they're using
orbital water so you're gonna have to
predict
at least pretty closely predict where
they're going to be and it's not easy
trust me it is not easy sometimes you
think they're going into the corner and
then they'll Dart over at the last
second so it's really hard to get that
just right unfortunately as you're going
to see here exploso is probably the best
option overall so I'm going to show you
all the other ones but if you want to
just instantly get out of orb of water
this is probably the best case scenario
now another spell that has a very
similar effect to expulso would be
inflatus the thing about inflatus is it
cost one more MP it does do more damage
and it does control them for a little
bit longer you know they're going to be
levitating there for a little bit the
problem with inflatus is the range is
only 20 and it to me it is so much
harder to hit with inflatus I know it's
only 28 versus 20 so like what exactly
does that translate to in the game it
feels like a big difference to me plus
you get the added cost of that one extra
MP and in that case I just don't think
it's worth it I do sometimes in Duos I
prefer to use inflatus because I don't
know in Duos it's like there's so much
action going on that a lot of times you
can catch people sleeping maybe they
just stand stationary in one spot they
think they're tucked away in a corner
and there's all this other stuff going
on and you don't notice them the other
thing that I really like about inflatus
and Duos is that when somebody's
Reviving you can use that to knock them
out of that as well so inflatus is also
a good option just know that it's going
to be a little bit harder to hit them
with that now another one that I really
don't see a lot of people using but is
also a good way of getting out of the
spell is the port key right here the
thing about the port key is that it is
also very unpredictable even though
you're casting it on yourself because
they have you in the orb of water and
they're moving you around you may not
hit exactly where you need to even if
you drop it right away if they're moving
around the orb of water then it may not
line up just right and you may not
teleport anywhere it may just drop the
port key right there that being said it
is a viable option and it is another way
that you can get out of the spell now
there are a couple of others that I
would think should be a lot better than
they actually end up being stupefy is
one of them but it is also unpredictable
and then the way that you cast Stupify
it's a little bit different instead of
trying to get the exact area it's like
you sort of have that lane where you're
casting expelliarmuses the same way so
with these two spells it can sometimes
work but unlike inflatus and unlike
expulso those when you hit it is a
guarantee yes it's hard to hit them but
when you hit it is for sure it is going
to knock them out of casting over water
and you will be free with Stupify I've
actually seen Stupify hit before and
then they still don't break free of the
orb of water I'm not sure if that's
intentional or if it's all about like
how far the Stupify launches them or the
exact point where the Stupify hits I'm
not sure kind of the same thing with
Expelliarmus there now if you happen to
be a new player and you are running
Tebow or you get Tebow to come up this
might be the best way to get out of a
form of water because if you watch up
here in the little preview window look
at that casting Lane it is just an
enormously wide area that if you can be
anywhere close to the person and it hits
you're going to be in a very good spot
it's going to knock them out of it and
then you will be free of orbital water
the thing about this one is unless
you're a new player you're probably not
going to have this card and even if
you're new you're probably not going to
have it in your deck you're probably
just waiting for it to pop up as a
random card I mean it costs 4 MP I
definitely don't think it's worth it to
have it in there strictly for getting
out of orb of water but if you're a new
player and Tebow comes up then that's
going to be a great way for you to get
out of it now similar to Port key you
also have side along Apparition this one
costs a little bit more it's 3MP however
this is a fantastic way essentially a
guaranteed way if you were caught in the
orb and you cast this you will get out
using side along Apparition the only
problem here is I mean it is strictly a
movement based spell whereas portkey
kind of has the added advantage of being
able to get people out of the nebulous
charm whenever they cast that you didn't
know that you can throw a port key in
and it'll actually break the nebulous
charm but with side along Apparition you
would essentially just be having it in
there as a movement spell that being
said if you got it if you're running it
it is a fantastic way to get out of the
orb of water now another one that will
get you out of it but only for a brief
time is the broomstick only cost 2 MP
it's actually a really fun spell to use
in a lot of decks I've been having a
blast with it lately however because it
returns you to the exact spot where you
cast it from it depends on the timing
you know when they cast orb of water
versus when you cast broomstick so it
will mitigate some of the damage you
won't take all the damage but the
problem is it returns you back to
exactly where you were so as long as
they weren't moving around while you
were casting that broomstick then you'll
just return right back to where you were
and you'll go right back into the orb
however it's such a low cost if it's
your only option it's probably worth
just going ahead and using it to
mitigate a little bit of that damage all
right so now let's say you're in a
situation where you don't have any of
those cards there's no way for you to
get out of the orb of water so then my
thought always goes to are there some
other things that I can do here based on
your MP what you currently have do you
want to use some other cards to inflict
damage on them because yes you're taking
a lot of damage and you're stuck in this
position they're also in somewhat of a
vulnerable position for example if you
are running thunderstorm
thunderstorm is a great card to throw
down while they're doing oral water
simply because they can't cast nebulous
there's no way they can avoid it unless
they have a lot of other summons on the
field of course then they're gonna
spread the damage around but let's say
it's just you one-on-one they cast over
water you're stuck in it and you have a
thunderstorm you have enough MP throw it
and then they're gonna take all of those
hits from that because they're just
stuck there holding over water on you
now one that I haven't tried personally
but I've read about this and thought
that actually makes a lot of sense
augmenti aguaminty is a really powerful
spell I use it a lot in the forest in
the PVE side of the game it's a little
bit harder in PvP because you know you
have to be lined up exactly where the
person is well it just so happens when
they're casting orbital water they are
perfectly in alignment with you so if
you have the spell if you're running it
in your PVP deck then that could be a
great opportunity to get some free
damage on them because it does so much
damage it's gonna do 10 Jets of water in
a straight line while you're stuck in
the orb of water you're lined up
perfectly it's a great opportunity to
cast that spell now another good one
here is atmospheric charm which you can
cast while they are casting orb of water
and then it'll just kind of follow them
around as they're moving good way to get
a little bit of damage I also forgot
here the howler it costs 4 MP so it's
probably not worth trying to use this
just to get out of the orb of water but
it does get you out of the orb of water
as well although that one there's a
little bit of hesitation I don't know if
you've played around with hell or too
much it is actually a really fun
powerful spell but there's a little bit
of a delay when it actually will
activate it has a wide range but it's
going to give them time to get out of it
so yes if you happen to catch someone in
the howler in the circle and they are
casting over water on you yes it would
knock them out of it and they also
forgot about accio Akio can sometimes
have a little bit of success as well
sort of similar to stupefy and
Expelliarmus and how that lane where you
cast it again though it cost 4 MP so
probably not worth using that as a way
to get out of the orb now let's talk
about some things you do not want to do
if you get stuck in the orb of water
because believe it or not you can take a
bad situation and make it much worse
first of all you you do not want to use
any of your summons when you're stuck in
the orb of water don't throw Cornish
Pixies don't drop a bomb box don't use
the cats don't use the monster book
don't throw down a centaur I mean don't
do any of these things that will summon
in other creatures because if you do
that they are going to get sucked into
the orb of water as well companions do
not bring in companions either because
they will just get sucked right in a lot
of times I don't know people think Ron
is just so op and he is very powerful
but people will bring Ron in when they
get stuck in the orb of water which do
not do that because then you're going to
lose Ron he's going to get sucked up in
the orbit water as well so you want to
be very very careful about that there's
a tendency when you get stuck in that
orb trust me I know it's so frustrating
you just want to look down and you just
want to start throwing cards out at them
you have to be careful take assessment
of the cards that you have first answer
can you get out of it if you can't ask
yourself can I do damage to them and is
it worth doing the damage to them or
would I be better off saving this MP
those are all the things that you got to
think about in those moments but again
what you do not want to do is just start
throwing your summons out there because
then you just wasted your MP alright so
let's take a look at a Duo's match up
here I was teaming up with swamp witch
from our community shout out to swamp
witch guys if you're not part of our
Discord yet check the video description
below make sure you join we have a very
active magical waking community and I've
been having an absolute blast playing
with you guys Duos Forest we've been
doing all kinds of things together in
this game and it is so much fun so
you're gonna get an example of I believe
two scenarios here
two times that orb of water is broken so
their swamp which casts it
and you can just see how when people are
stuck in that there's not a lot they can
do now the other person there they
immediately cast it as well confringo
swamp which cask and fringo it did not
break
or out of it
incendio confringo those types of spells
good ways to do damage while you're
stuck in it but they're not gonna break
you free of it so I believe it's going
to be a little bit before we see the
next orb of Water cast so I get the
potato diabolic going and they are not
happy about that they're gonna try to
get me out of it here with a couple of
incendios I thought I was actually safe
right there so that's why I didn't leave
at first but then another one I go ahead
and use broomstick to escape it for a
little bit
there's so much happening on screen in
Duos matches I love it it's absolutely
crazy if you got two runs on the field
now swamp which has got the Death Eaters
so there's another over water now watch
Swamp witch watch watch watch watch
exploso in the back corner
the esposo in that back corner a lot of
times people gravitate to the corners
for some reason whenever they're casting
over water so she was able to predict
that movement see where the player was
going to be hit him with the exploso and
then it breaks the orb of water
now there's going to be another one here
in this in a second
you gotta watch really closely
to see how this one is broken actually
I'm gonna switch to uh let's go to swamp
Patrol okay so there's the orb of water
what broke me out of that right there
oh my goodness
I'm gonna have to go back and watch that
I could not see what broke me out of it
so now we've got
a decent control of the fight
swamp which has got to watch her health
at 347 there get the thunderstorm going
they do have a Cassandra out oh that the
witch snowball
yeah so she goes down right there
but I have one down I'm just gonna go
ahead and revive even though I do have
the inflatus and then I immediately I
think I try to fire the inflatus off
right here oh no orb of water of course
orbital water is going to end out the
game so guys I really hope this helps
you out with orb of water check the
video out next over on the right side of
the screen YouTube thinks that would be
a great one for you and as always thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon